التحقيقات في تسريب وثائق البنتاغون تركز
على صحه الصور المنشوره على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي والجهات المسؤوله عن التسريب
ونطاقه كما اتخذ البنتاغون اجراءات تتعلق
بكيفيه توزيع المعلومات السريه داخل
الحكومه الامريكيه والاشخاص المخولين
بالاطلاع عليها
نتعامل مع قضيه تسريب الوثائق بجديه بالغه
وسنواصل التحقيق ولن ندخر جهدا الى حين
العثور على مصدر هذا التسريب والمدى الذي
بلغه
وتثير التسريبات قلقا بالغا لدى الاداره
الامريكيه جراء تداعياتها المحتمله امنيا
وتهديدها لسلامه عدد من العملاء
فالوثائق التي قد تحتوي على معلومات حساسه
بالغه السريه تتناول تقييمات للحرب في
اوكرانيا ومعطيات حول تدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه وتجهيزها كما تكشف في حال
صحتها عن تجسس الولايات المتحده على
الرئيس الاوكراني وكوريا الجنوبيه ووزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ومجموعه فاجنر اضافه الى
الموساد الاسرائيلي ومصر والامارات
الامريكيه الى معرفه اي من الوثائق جرى
تصويرها ومن المخول بالحصول عليها وهذه هي
نقطه البدايه لان هذه المستندات ليست
متاحه لجميع من يملكون تصريحا امنيا ويعد
تسريب وثائق البانتاجون الاوسع خلال العقد
الماضي منذ قيام ادوارد سنودن المتعاقدي
مع وكاله الامن القومي الامريكيه بتسريب
الاف الوثائق السريه عام 2013
يواصل البانتاجون ووزاره العدل ووكالات
الحكوميه امريكيه اخرى التحقيقات في تسريب
الوثائق السريه ومحاوله حصر نطاقها خوفا
من تسريبات اضافيه لمعلومات حساسه وسريه
فدي منصور الجزيره من البانتاجون